la Gamer a semblé 2006 se déroule tout
ce week-end au Futuroscope il s'agit du
plus grand rassemblement français de
passionnés de jeux vidéo cette année un
jeu est à l'honneur World of Warcraft
reportage de Gravel et Thomas chapuseau
la bête et gardée comme un secret
des chaînes les passions dans la
communauté Warcraft pourtant elle n'a
aucune utilité
et c'est certainement le petit
personnage le plus le plus attendu au
niveau du jeu pour les joueurs c'est
c'est un petit animal qui peut vous
suivre il a toute une histoire
ça c'est le petit bébé il y a des
adultes en jeu
si vous demandez au genre de vous faire
le crimeur qui pourront vous le faire
ici on a le toune c'est un match vous
l'aurez compris ces joueurs font partie
d'un univers à part c'est l'univers de
World of Warcraft un monde médiéval et
fantastique plus proche du jeu de rôle
que du jeu traditionnel un jeu
multijoueur en ligne qui compte déjà un
million d'afficionados en Europe pour la
première fois il est présenté dans une
lande partie comprenait une assemblée de
joueurs en réseau
c'est ça c'est pouvoir rencontrer
discuter avec des gens qu'on n'aurait
jamais croisé surtout ce serait jamais
arrêté
d'univers totalement différent des
étudiants des des du travail des gens
chômage et des gens qu'on n'aurait pas
pu rencontrer ailleurs c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans les jours en réseau
World of Warcraft et le succès de
l'année 2005 en matière de jeux vidéo un
monde dans lequel il existe autant de
personnalités que de joueurs il
rassemble des passionnés dans des
guildes comprenez et des groupes de
joueurs qui font partie de la même façon
gnome elfe de la nuit ou encore mage à
chacun son rôle c'est sympa de jouer
avec des gens qu'on connaît pas
forcément on va leur demander de grouper
pour faire une quête et tuer des
monstres ensemble et puis peut-être
après continuer je sais pas mais ouais
on peut c'est sympa quoi des gens comme
ça mise à jour en ligne tous les mois le
jeu est en perpétuel évolution jusqu'à
lundi plus de 130 joueurs s'affront au
Futuroscope ils sont déjà plus de 6
millions à travers le monde
sur Internet une connexion et un
abonnement suffisent à vivre des
aventures virtuelles dans des mondes
féeriques et ce sont des millions de
joueurs qui se passionnent pour ces jeux
collectifs Emmanuel Lambert Édouard
Perrin
des héros vaillants un vaste monde en
guerre
des créatures hostiles bienvenue dans
Warcraft ce jeu est un phénomène
et jour 7 millions de personnes du monde
entier se connectent sur internet pour
s'affronter soldat magicien chasseur
chaque joueur crée un personnage un
avatar évoluant dans un monde virtuel
sans fin
c'est plutôt
comme si l'on ouvre un livre qu'on se
plongeait dedans et qu'on pouvait en
quelque sorte en écrire certaines pages
dans le jeu Guidi et carnagette son chef
de guilde sous leur commandement virtuel
50 personnes qu'il faut gérer il faut
quand même consacrer un petit peu de
temps la gestion mais tout dépend de la
place qu'on a qu'une maladie puisque une
ville c'est comme toute communauté
humaine c'est organisé donc des
personnes qui vont être spécialisées qui
vont s'investir pour la gestion du forum
ou bien pour l'organisation d'événements
sont très rentables pour leur créateurs
en plus du coup du sélérum chaque joueur
doit payer un abonnement mensuel jouer
régulièrement pendant un an revient à
215 euros et les joueurs sont de plus en
plus nombreux c'est ça qui est aussi
magique dans l'internet c'est que vous
allez retrouver homme femme enfant jeune
ado
des cadres dynamiques des ouvriers et
c'est ça qui est génial parce que en
plus étant donné qu'on a tous des
avatars on est tous égaux voici Florian
alias Mamytwink depuis cinq ans cet
étudiant en informatique se passionne
pour World of Warcraft un jeu de rôle en
réseau qui permet d'évoluer dans un
univers fantastique
on incarne un personnage virtuel
personnage qu'on doit entraîner
améliorer en faisant des quêtes tuant
des monstres on va gagner des points
d'expérience qui vont nous permettre
d'augmenter nos caractéristiques ce
groupe avec d'autres joueurs rencontrer
d'autres joueurs pour ensuite aller
jouer l'ordinateur depuis décembre
dernier Florian anime avec les moyens du
bord une émission hebdomadaire dédiée au
jeu c'est la seule du genre diffusée en
langue française sur le net
l'objectif de l'émission c'est
principalement de parler du jeu donc
d'apporter des petites astuces des
petites news mais aussi de divertir les
joueurs en présentant des choses
inutiles et comme on aime le dire donc
indispensable pour les amuser pour les
faire rire quoi depuis sa mise en ligne
l'émission cartonne on compte jusqu'à 30
000 connexions à chaque diffusion
[Musique]
je me suis aperçu qu'effectivement il y
avait pas d'émission de ce type pour ce
jeu je me disais quand même que ça
pouvait quand même bien marcher mais
c'est vrai qu'on a eu un énorme succès
et que c'était que ça c'était une
attendue un succès inattendu autour d'un
jeu très populaire World of Warcraft
réunis 250 000 joueurs en France et 12
millions dans le monde
[Musique]